we're also the people that vac create
human experience in way because the the
spaces we're in if that's the thesis of
this conversation in a way they
influence the way we think yes the way
we feel the way we make decisions boom
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host I'll sake on we are in Los
Angeles California we are going to be
talking about all things architecture
all things design all things
understanding what actually goes in to
building these buildings that we all
have the pleasure and honor to actually
walk into and be a part of on a daily
basis we are sitting down with evident
bliss pleasure to be here Allen what's
of it well too long my face a bit too
long too evident I actually went to high
school together ten years ago and here
we are now later in life just feel it
doesn't even feel like I don't think I
could have ever predicted this in the
best of ways right yeah he's in LA doing
badass work in architecture and design
I'm in San Francisco doing badass work
and interviewing so it's exciting that
we both made the trek out to California
and also it feels like we're just you
know just too high and high she's like
coming home like we're just tight like
we've had both good consciousness
expansions from coming to California and
we vibe we vibe great so everyone I
think it's so important we're going to
start with them some some big history as
we jump into things but quick on Evans
background I want to introduce you guys
to what his background is so he has a
Bachelor of Science and designer
architecture at the University of braska
Lincoln then he has master's in
architecture from the University of
Illinois in Chicago then he spent two
years at Clive Wilkinson architects then
he spent one year currently board of
directors of Los Angeles form for
architecture and urban design and six
months the most recently as the design
director at alloy architecture and
construction and he is spent the last
two months as an instructor at UCLA
Extension architecture and interior
design program so you're already doing
teaching now UCLA's extension program
that's dope you've had a lot of great
experience at different
architectural firms and you have a
really good abstract perspective on
architecture which I love so much so
before we get into the nuance of that
let's do a big history synthesis on
reality here we are
evolution long period of evolution we're
stewards of earth now we're hockey
sticking up in population and
exponential technology what is your
current synthesis of the state of
humanity humanity that's a big question
for from a big-big personnel and uh I
love that okay so obviously I'm gonna
have my specific lens on it so I I think
it's best that I speak about it in terms
of in terms of architecture so I might
have to start a little bit abstract for
myself and kind of parse out what what
parts of that I'd like to hone in on I
think I think over the course of talking
to you over the last couple days maybe
it's become apparent that I think
culture is really the part of humanity
that most interest me I think there's a
lot of other practitioners in
architecture in in other technical and
artistic disciplines that very much
concerned themselves with I guess the
notions of how do we you know how do we
mitigate overuse of water how do we
utilize sustainable materials how do we
use the raw matter in the most efficient
way I would say for me I'm I'm equally
interested in how do we somewhat in the
Elon Musk sort of way how do we how do
we assure that the future that were
pursuing is when we're excited about
which to me is essentially a cultural
problem so I would say that everything I
do in architecture is is with that in
mind with that approach in mind that
it's really about curating a cultural
condition through design and
architecture that that makes life a
really compelling experience for
everybody right
I know that's abstract but I know that's
a good whack that that's a that's a good
one because when when we when we look
around us we we spoke a lot about
communication we're gonna dive in a
visit to some ethos stuff in a little
bit but when we when we look or when we
talk to people communicate to people the
you know the building's that we go into
also communicate to us and we indicate
with them so building them in a way that
gets us excited in a sustainable and
ecological and technically exciting way
um excites us as a communication fabric
for where we're heading so that's good
that you have that lens and then I want
to ask you you know as we get more into
the weeds one more kind of abstract
please with that is we looking around us
here in downtown Los Angeles we have a
lot of you know a lot of these you know
late 1800s Early 1900s mid 1900s style
construction where things look a little
bit more than you can obviously describe
this better but concrete II bricky or
yeah not non-porous monolithic yeah
which I would argue Allen that that's
interesting you hit immediately on that
I would argue that that manifestation is
a direct cultural message that's being
sent as you can see a lot a lot of the
names you're seeing on these buildings
are banks they're accounting firms
they're the the vestiges of the
financial industry right through
conveying a message about their
prominence through architecture so I
think that's a great example
really and we now mike follow-ups that
is where would you like to see how will
you because you have so many good actual
designs that you've made yourself of the
future of architecture where do you see
us transitioning as the newer era of
buildings come into play
100% well I think it'll be far less
hierarchically oriented so I think
there's sort of certainly this kind of
attitude about as you say a monolithic
quality of institutions asserting their
dominance over the population in a way
not to not to make this some sort of
power struggle dynamic necessarily but I
think that's certainly imbued on every
level I look at design as having a value
in the sense that it can certainly bring
people together it can it can be a
mechanism that allows the collective
cultural values to be projected so it's
not only kind of a temperature reading
of how people in our society are feeling
because we're driven I mean I think
architecture is just is kind of it
adhered to market forces and adhere to
cultural forces as any other discipline
but it also has that element of of the
practitioners being the folks that are
both both interpreting what's happening
on the ground
culturally amongst people but also
projecting a kind of collective ideal
that they see for for design like design
being both a passive and an active
intervention in society
so I I've always thought that it design
is actually political sense right it's
it's not necessarily in the left versus
right way but in a sense that it
influences
I hope shirt like you were saying
earlier yeah it influences the structure
and in the kind of interrelations of
people people so so when you when you
build a building without the intention
of people connecting to earth then
people don't get to connect to earth
exactly when you build it with us
porosity for natural light to come
through like the holes of a sponge and
when you build it with the intent of it
being ecologically friendly that you can
breathe in fresh air from from trees
that you can see green around you that
you can have the proper recycling
systems all this type of stuff inside
that you know that further connects
people in ok let's jump into a little
bit more of this nuance now so ok so you
find yourself you find yourself doing
architecture and design through the
through through a bachelor's and
master's and then you you know you get
yourself out in Los Angeles you're going
through these firms what is one of these
you know these profound takeaways for
you as you're going through the
different firms because people design
different buildings there's the office
buildings there's hospitals there's
schools
there's residential there's so many
different designs and they all have
somewhat of a similar you have to lug
materials in you have to do electrical
retinyl concerns always and air
conditioning and plumbing etcetera all
this stuff and there's contractors and
yeah so to tell ya take teachers about
this it's really a dance right I mean so
I I look at the architect is sort of the
would you say the the conductor of the
orchestra
like we're not.we we have the asset and
the advantage of being by our training
generally generalists right we we have
to know a little bit about everything we
have to know enough to be dangerous in
all those various disciplines and
considerations you mentioned and and in
practice that that turns into us kind of
guiding the direction in the intent of
each one of those individual practices
so whether it be in a particular
building the the ventilation system has
a really strong impact on the end
results of the design or it's it's it's
deeply part of the conceptual
understanding of this building then the
architect needs to be adept at
communicating that to their mechanical
engineer to make sure that that part of
the building is is done properly within
the kind of design direction so that's
really what we are is we have our deep
domain expertise in architecture where
you know we we have our rudiments where
we know how to draw we know how to
create imagery that sells an idea we
know how to create imagery that digests
and unpacks the technical data behind
the designs we make but at the end of
the day I look at us as once again kind
of communicators with with a broad
constituency of other professionals
so it's it's for me it's very liberating
for what I would say a person like me
who's considers himself a kind of a
40,000 foot type type thinker so walk us
through this as you going through these
different firms and you're going through
school and whatnot
how are you actually you're dealing with
offices hospitals schools residential
how are you picking how do firms look
how do the schools and hospitals and
stuff generally contract the stuff out
how do you then generally contract out
to the different engineers and civil
civil engineers plumbers electricians
etc how does that whole entire thing
happen well it's it's really a I would
say a professional ecosystem not
terribly dissimilar from any other one
in the sense that you have generally you
have a team that's that's kind of
ongoing because these things are all
about relationships right when you work
with one structural engineer they start
to understand maybe not your style but
the way that you might structure your
designs or your architectural thinking
so they can be one step ahead and kind
of help you help you improve your
ability to execute on those designs
because they're there preemptively sort
of reading what you might do you build
up that rapport in that relationship
with their consultant teams with your
structural engineers with your
mechanical engineers and it also just
improves the speed to market right if
you have a team if you got if you got a
few guys or girls you can call right
away when you get projects and you know
they'll help deliver what you need it's
it's it's frankly just like any other
industry it's it's all about
relationships and
and once again any any time in the
creative fields as well that there's
that kind of extra layer of something
beyond just the practical and just in
just the financial and it's not just
about hey which engineers got the
cheapest feet you know it's it's also
about who's gonna help me really build
that badass cantilever that the city the
city will approve and nose in nose and
is willing to tackle that problem of a
you know an avant-garde structural
design because I in my experience I
found that sometimes you do encounter
engineers that that will tell you you
can't do something but there might be a
way to do it it's just it just takes a
lot of work so so like anything it you
have to you have to kind of love it to
make it happen and want to make it
happen let me see if I can hit this what
a team that loves it right yes so let me
see how you hit this so then you'll get
a you'll get potentially a hospital
school office etc will will look at a
bunch of different architectural firms
and they'll maybe just reach out to them
and then those architectural firms will
provide you guys will will sketch things
out by hand and then by CAD and and and
explore what it would be like to submit
you know designs for them and and then
something that's interesting that you
were teaching you about and then that
you know you obviously go off if you get
them if you get the bid and go out and
contract people and actually go and
build it out but you were teaching me a
lot about ethos I thought this was
really interesting you guys worked on a
project that was from medical facility
for a physical therapy um and so you had
to design the interior of this building
to be very for four different physical
therapy you want to inspire people but
for like a traumatic brain injury you
don't want it to be like too bright in
too excitable and stuff like that yes so
yeah so teach us about how you blend
when they give you an ethos how you
design towards that ethos i and that's
just on that's on the money for for how
I frame up really any architectural
design problem in an office or otherwise
starting with what are the what are the
real cultural and human implications of
this design brief I've been given by a
client so that particular project here
alluding to was I would number one I
would say was incredibly unique so it it
was a project I was privileged to work
on at a Clive Wilkinson architects and
she mentioned earlier and it was also it
was framed up in a very unique way
because the client understood our
offices particular expertise in office
design so we've been known for quite a
quite a period of time probably 20-plus
years as being really a firm that
understood how to create an open office
which for better for worse is is getting
a little bit of cultural pushback now
but
understood how to make an open office
that really communicated the ideals of
an organization of a company and also
created a space in which they could work
most effectively so it it started with
culture it started with interviewing the
executives with interviewing the project
managers interviewing the staff to
understand intimately what other needs
both practically and culturally to best
do their work
so this rehabilitation Institute in
Chicago came to us with that knowledge
and asked us can you take that
particular approach and apply it to our
design problem which is how do we create
a rehabilitation Institute that breaks
down the barriers between those who
practice the rehabilitation those that
are on the ground actually helping
people physically in real time better
themselves get back to you know full
mobility how do you fuse that with the
kind of the research that's happening on
the other end and perhaps in an isolated
institution physically geographically
intellectually separated from the actual
work that's being done and they were
convinced and and we agreed that that
some of the principles that we had
developed through our office design
experience could be applied
through this institution and then how do
you go about taking an ethos like that
yes and then actually bring it into
designing the space 100% so a couple
things the design problem itself the
client asked us to do that we design the
patient experience which is a very
abstract ask but we define that as what
the patient sees experiences feels from
the minute they show up to to when
they've came up to the floors when
they're when they're actively being real
rehabilitated that whole narrative along
the way is what our problem is right so
that that manifested in very simple but
provocative and thoughtful ways I would
say one of them being that graphics were
a very strong component of what we did
so thinking about architecture not just
as bricks and mortar but also a surface
treatment as the way that you think
about colors and the way that you think
about how those colors affect one's mood
and one's understanding of what the
space they've just entered represents or
is trying to do for them so a really
good example is how we thought about the
ambulance entry which I think I already
mentioned to you so oh yeah it's just
you know it's such a it's such a simple
idea but it's like how do these how do
these patients come into this space how
do they come into this Rehabilitation
Institute they're coming in on an
ambulance they're on the back-right and
they're in a very traumatic State I get
a very a compromised state and they need
they need something that really envelops
them and and reassures them and lets
them know that they're at a place where
people care and they're here to help you
right
so the way that we translated that was
we we thought about the kind of entry
Bay to the building rather than it being
this dark dank utilitarian forgotten
space where there's you know there's
water leaking
you know those cracks in the walls
everything's just dismal we thought
about it as a place of not over
stimulating but something that kind of
projected an air of freshness of
cleanness so it's it's these kind of
curvilinear graphics that are orange
tones which are the brand tones of this
particular organization and just kind of
projects this idea of a coming home in a
way right through through this graphic
treatment there's like a heart and
there's yeah there's a compassion
feeling exactly that's a great thank you
very much thank you for those words at
compassion precisely so it from from day
one from moment one we're communicating
something and then I can kind of walk
you through the building so this this
particular project it was broken up into
I believe four or five floors each floor
dedicated to a particular rehabilitation
type whether that be sort of arms and
hands so people that have hand and
injuries and have these kind of
microscale fine-grain maneuvers that
they have to to kind of relearn or go
through that experience of relearning
those that are basically need to relearn
how to walk so the kind of legs and
walking floor as you alluded to those
that have brain injuries traumatic brain
injuries that
/ it's a very different experience from
that very physical side of
rehabilitation and then and then I
believe just a strength floor for those
that doesn't have need to be
rehabilitated in general strength dam so
you're designing a different aesthetic
an environment for every single one of
those physical yes areas for
rehabilitation and treatment
yeah therapy that's so cool right and
and the thing is that I think where this
really became a novel approaches if you
think about it if you just take a second
and you think about what does a hospital
look like what does a rehabilitation
institute look like it looks very
monolithic right it's it's we see that
you know the drab hallways the endless
kind of beige this very frankly an
environment that's I think inherently
not conducive to what what we're trying
to do for the people that are in the
space right you need something that's
catered to them that that is catered to
their emotional state not just the
practical solving of you know how do we
get you back to strong again and active
again and capable again but how do we
this is just as much an emotional thing
as it is a physical thing
so that was front of mind when we were
designing these spaces so each of those
spaces it in a very real and physical
way manifests differently so I was I was
charged primarily with designing the
brain floor which differentiated from
the kind of arms and hands and the
strength and the legs and walking it
eated a very at least by our measure
from from thinking about it critically
from speaking to the leadership at the
Rehabilitation Institute from actually
visiting there I got to fly to Chicago
meet with the staff there to actually
see what was happening and understand
that intimately
it was understood that this brain floor
needed a very almost kind of a nurturing
sort of aesthetic and a nurturing sort
of organization and sense to it so it
it's organized in a way that all the
kind of more active parts of the
rehabilitation are happening on the
center of the floor right and then on
the edges of the floor on the periphery
are these kind of sculptural type scoops
and and gestures if your listeners go
and take a look at we're gonna we're
gonna plug in these images you'll be
seeing them right now yeah so you'll
understand that they're they're kind of
these scalloped takes shapes almost like
spherical or almost arched like that
have a almost ancient softness to them
that are also covered with these soft
blue graphics that it feels almost like
a sky like almost the the the the mist
and the gradient of sky enveloping you
so that's where these very sensitive
rehabilitation actions are happening
it's cut on the edges but it's
simultaneously projecting this idea and
this intention of intimacy by creating
these little break off hooks but also
understanding that there needs to be a
clear dialogue happening on across the
floor that activities that are happening
in the rehabilitation that's happening
in the center of the floor needs to be
physically and and communicational II
proximate to the kind of edge conditions
yeah
it was so so nuts listening to you talk
about this because it it's this reminds
us continuously reminds me about the
sheer complexity of the world around us
like when we walk into a restaurant
we're not actually thinking about how
they source the food the bussers the
waiters the chefs the management how
they designed the actual venue where
you're sitting all this kind of stuff
seems similar to when the future is not
these monolithic buildings with these
hospital hallways that are just beige
and whatnot but it's this warm and
inviting all the way from when you first
park your car it's a warm and inviting
environment for you to come in knowing
that you're gonna be compassionately
taken care of and then there's a
different on every floor for every
single different treatment every therapy
that's happening here so thinking about
it in that lens is totally part of this
future of where we think about design in
a new way and I Anna and I love I love
that now now that that's a really good
powerful example for hospitals now I
want you to also touch on the ethos for
offices this is also yes interesting so
you'll you'll be going and you were
talking about this you flew to Chicago
to talk with them you know when you have
these these these these meetings with
let's say the company that's coming in
that wants their that wants their office
design you'll have a conversation with
them about their ethos about what they
want to see in our office and then you
guys manifest that through your designs
and so tell us about that process right
well you know frankly Alan I don't think
it's terribly different than what you do
fascinatingly enough I think I think we
all think you know architects and
designers there's so much different than
me or there that what they do is is so
unique and perhaps it is in some ways
but I think it's really just about
asking great questions which
you spoke to and a lot of your work and
I think great architects know how to do
that with their clients like they they
know how to ask the right level of
questions that it's it makes enough
assumptions that you can frame-up what
you're perhaps trying to get from them
from the conversation but not so
specific that it forces a certain answer
right which is a very difficult thing to
do and it's it's it's a very human and a
very emotional and a very soft skills
approach right so and I think the thing
is from my experience that you get
different types of clients - I would say
in offices they tend to be a little bit
more oriented that way naturally like I
think they understand that their
organization is a complex organism and
then it has all these particulars about
it that that they're asking you as the
designer to parse through and assess and
then give them deliver them and a
solution that is is filtering your
subjectivity of what they are through
the practicality of of you know this is
how the desks are arranged this is what
materials we're using this is the
natural light we're bringing into the
building it's it's a high-level question
not not so much a laundry list of of
preconceived answers about I you know I
need this many desks or I need this many
soft chairs I need this many floors even
I think the best office projects I've
ever worked on had they've started more
abstract and then you end up with the
result that could never have been
predicted on day one and and I and
that's in a good in a good way not not
in just a crazy way one example I can
think of I actually only had a kind of a
relatively small part on this project
but it was a
a project we did at Clive's office for a
French advertising agency Publicis
Groupe
which perhaps you've heard of it they
had asked us to design their new New
York North American headquarters in New
York City and they they have zero
assigned deaths in the whole complex of
interest which is kind of incredible
right it and that's just something that
I don't think could have ever been
generated if if day one conversation was
here's how many employees we had which
I'm sure that conversation was had it's
like here's how many employees we had
but but the the boundaries and and the
question was loose enough that you could
say it's not about how many employees we
have it's about what our employees need
do they need to be tied to a desk do
they perhaps instead need many different
working options can we provide a whole
gradient and a whole meal ooh of
different choices for these workers that
you come in every day and if it's it's a
heads-down focus day we have that
environment that we've created for you
whether it's a private it's a private
booth it's a phone booth it's it's a
conference room just for you and your
four closest associates to hash out you
know a really important problem or maybe
some days like you need that coffee bar
that that really central hub inside the
office where you can all convene and you
can trade ideas and you can really get a
read on what everybody's up to and
perhaps translate that into what your
workgroup is doing so it's that's really
what I mean I hope that's a more
tangible and practical way of saying
that's that's how you start with culture
as a designer I love that I love that
your emphasis on culture and
communications and ethos in this in the
push for design is so incredibly
important and I'm glad that you're
disseminating that as your first
principle and a lot of the prominent
architects that you surround yourself
with carry that is their first principle
so that's how this this is a good
dissemination for other people to latch
on and be like whoa we should be seeing
the world through through this lens as
we construct and build
I want you to speak on um on
technicalities sure so yeah there's is
it to leading software's rhino and Revit
are this leading software's for
designing I would say in a contemporary
environment yeah in a contemporary
environment and so when you're when
you're using these software's this is
kind of like in a in a little bit of
like a three-dimensional computer aided
design II style CAD environment and
you're able to take what you're
visualizing from that ethos and
communication with the org and put that
into a digital yeah and then so tell us
about that and then how that how that
the technical tool will then translate
into the final promise yeah I love this
I love this Allen because it I want to
make up micro aside before we took right
into that I I think you are giving me a
great you're providing a great example
of why the outside the outsiders
sometimes the best person to have a
conversation about a field because
they're not going to make the same
presumptions about the conversation
because one thing that sort of exists in
my field is a really would you say
almost oppressive kind of separation
between the technical people and
the design people and I love that this
conversation right here it's like we can
talk culture but now we're going let's
like talk about software let's talk
about what do you what's the super
technical in the weeds thing that you're
doing I mean I think cons have the same
issue with engineers and sales people
exactly that's a great way to
characterize it and I think that just
speaks to that it's a very human thing
at night and maybe that's the other
vision for the future for you know I
think collectively maybe we can start to
bridge that divide yeah
but to get into your question
specifically so I I I am very much
aligned with Revit I that's what I use
every day and I there's there's haters
there's lovers of Revit I at this point
honestly man I'm I would put myself in
the lovers camp it it's just so so
useful it where it differentiates from
other software's and I don't know how
much your audience is familiar with CAD
drafting software's or 3d modeling
software how they've really existed in
the past is that when you model
something in 3d or when you draw a line
in in the autocad space that line
doesn't have a property beyond just
being a line or a volume like the
software doesn't have the intelligence
it doesn't have the data mining to
assign the properties of what that thing
actually means and by thing I mean when
you when you extruder you create a
volumetric rectangle in a 3d modeling
software you're representing a wall if
you're if you're modeling architecture
right here it has a thickness it's
perhaps four and seven eighths inch
thick which is pretty standard with you
know a but two-by-four stud and then
your 5/8 chipboard on each beside the
Supermicro here for you love that that's
great that's great do - I love micro
welcome but what's incredible about
Revit is that it's what we call a
building information modeling software
so that's BIM
for short and what that means is when
when you're drawing a wall and Revit
when you're drawing that that one hour
rated four and 7/8 inch wall the sulfur
actually has a whole list of properties
associated with that automatically
generated so there's kind of cool it's
it's less like starting super abstract
and it kind of gives you a kit of parts
in a way that you start with say sketch
does that a little bit too for the yep
first for technical people that are
building interfaces for you like user
interfaces for apps that they have any
sort of little kit components they're
like little plugins that you can plug in
that that's interesting just a quick
quick question please why four and seven
eighths instead of five like what's the
deal I know well what you know I think
it's I mean you might know this this is
I would say this is relatively common
knowledge if you know anything about
construction is so there's nominal
dimensions and real dimensions for studs
right like I'm gonna hear somebody say a
2x4 a 2x4 isn't actually 2x4 what it's
not right it's it's it's to one and a
half by three and a half inches in
profile so right there could be
different lengths that you buy for 2x4
just simply means cut through it it's
it's the actual dimensions the length in
the height right yeah yeah two inches
four inches as a piece of wood and what
did you say it actually is instead of it
saying I hope I'm not miss speaking here
the standard is it's usually four and
seven eighths so help my mass coming out
right there it is a 5/8 inch gypsum
board on either side for sheathing on
the other side for in 7/8
so okay sorry instead of instead of
going super technical why don't you do
this because you're actually you're
hitting on something interesting tell us
about these other component modules that
you can plug in because that was an
interesting one what are the other ones
can you just like oh yeah click on like
something to help you with like the
electrical and the plumbing yes yes so
let's I love this let's go super
technical so this will it'll require a
little bit of history about how
architecture is practiced so in the past
when we were coordinating with our
mechanical engineers or with our
structure
engineers we would trade what we call
CAD backgrounds so an architect would
generate their kind of latest drawings
their floorplan drawings their section
drawings so those are cut through the
building vertically you would provide
those drawings to your consultant team
as backgrounds and then the consultant
team would go in and they would draw in
their ducts they would they would route
all their ducks they would specify where
certain structural members would go so
they would specify where beams of a
certain depth are required because of
structural calculations but this was all
done primarily in two dimensions and it
was done primarily in a in a way that
the drawing was divorced from the actual
properties of each beam that was being
drawn right it was just simply lying
once again line works that was being
created lines that were drawn in them
that word either provided in a table of
values about what that particular beam
was or it was labeled it wasn't actually
associated in a smart way in real time
within the software so what's incredible
about Revit the BIM software is that the
3d modeled BIM model that we create we
can trade off with our structural
engineer now instead of them translating
two-dimensional data line work to
three-dimensional data about the
structural properties or the deduct
routing now they can actually model
their ducks in 3d and yeah and each one
of those Ducks has a property so instead
of it being a schematic line on a page
it's now a you know a 30-inch wide duck
that has a certain air volume and
there's every every line item of its
properties on it so it started like a 2d
line being the duct yeah and then it and
then you would actually make it this
actual rectangle that has an air volume
and then that would plug into the rest
of the three-dimensional model yeah
that's really cool and it's powerful
because it allows for what we typically
term clash detection so as you can
imagine and when you go inside a typical
building you often see those kind of
gridded ceilings the we call a CT
acoustical ceiling tiles right it's kind
of that
I would argue not the most aesthetically
moving away from them but above that you
often find all the guts to the building
right it's that all your ducks are
routed through out there all your your
structural members are up there so
that's stuff that's happening in three
dimensions so you can imagine in the
past when we were doing that in 2d oh
yeah most people don't even know that
the guts are up there yeah it's always
interesting lifting it up moving it to
the side and see if that's oh yeah total
so maybe yeah what's great about this
BIM software is now all that action
that's happening with the Ducks is are
routing up and down there changing
vertically there they have to route
around water piping they have to route
around structural members instead of
trying to make sure we're not screwing
that up into the heat we can actually 3d
model and coordinate that together like
we can trade models that are 3d okay
powerful all right that's so cool bit on
the technical side get out here geeking
out I love it there's some interesting
ways for you for us to be able to better
understand the nuance of things
literally just look at one of those
acoustic tiles lift it up move it over
to the side and you look up into that
space because you'll have some
interesting stuff also when you're just
in buildings just think about the
hundreds of people that went into the
process of designing and architecting
and moving the materials there
everything I want to ask you about this
major move of human animals to
Metropolis Wow okay okay so human
animals are moving by the droves to Los
Angeles and New York San Francisco Tokyo
Beijing Hong Kong Shanghai London Paris
etc we're moving to Metropolis away from
the rural environments you and I went
from Sioux Falls South Dakota with
150,000 people to these multi million
person cities so how are how do you see
what's happening there with people
moving away from the 3,000 square foot
houses into the 300 square foot shoebox
apartments so tell us about what you see
with that transition and what that means
with architecture and design yeah you
know Alan this is so timely because I I
was actually just at a talk last week I
hear we went
the guy I mentioned this to you I was at
a talk with the Urban Land Institute and
there was a company the CEO of a company
called Ollie that was speaking there and
so always a pretty unique business they
there I I can't comment exactly on what
they do in terms of their classification
whether they're a developer or a
consulting agency but what they've
managed to do is to crack the code the
building code in New York City to allow
micro units which by micro units we mean
sub 300 square foot apartments to be
buildable by code in in New York City
but on top of that what they've done is
not only allow that to happen
practically to allow it to be
financially viable to allow it to be
ethically and legally viable maybe I
don't know but I think we have a legal e
viable they've also layered on this
whole other approach about this not just
being about a lack of space in cities at
which you know in some ways it's driven
by that these first tier cities are
running out of space and in some ways or
they're running out of reasonably priced
base with suit both so it's not only
solving the problem of putting more
people in a smaller space it's as as I
would say it's also solving a cultural
problem right so I I would I would take
it to the next level and say that all
this stuff is equally happening because
of cultural reasons that it that are
probably driven in large part by social
media the network effect people want to
live among other high profile productive
people roaring in the metropolis is
gonna be closer to millions of people
and also you're talking about the
shoebox style designs where literally
the beds are folding up into the walls
the couches can push into the walls and
out and sit on and push them into the
wall the dressers can be pushed into the
wall pulled out yeah etc this is so
modular ice-t-- yeah yeah and what I
liked about how all he framed it up was
they said why why have we always thought
about
apartments and housing as distinct from
products like product designs and
commodities and and consumer goods
because at the end of the day I mean in
some ways that is what you're providing
if you're if you're a developer of
apartments you're providing a product
that that folks can can buy like can buy
into they can rent so in that sense that
product needs to have all the features
right it it's not just a space you're
giving them you're giving them a whole
built out space in the case of this
company as you're saying like every all
that necessary baseline furniture is
built into the walls it's it's
specifically catered so that you can
come in on it you can come in on
maneuver with your your your bag of
stuff your couple duffel bags and you're
set for the next year or two years you
don't need to bring anything else to the
table and and what I also thought was
incredibly compelling is they weren't
just solving the problem of the
individual unit they were also folding
in this idea of how do we make Ollie a
lifestyle brand how do we make it how do
we have this community organizing
element that they actually provide each
of their residents a membership to their
club right so it's a social club - it's
if the building has shared amenities
which a lot of apartment things happen
they've kind of institutionalized as
part of the business model as part of
buying into that unit if you pay rent
you're automatically part of the social
club that has events that has ski trips
that has a whole you know
yup dinner's Fitness is all this
different type of stuff it's not today I
feel like I'm Jenny wait quick a quick
bit on that it's really crazy that
Millennials and Gen Z you mentioned it
earlier just kind of in the most crazy
way moving into these urban environments
with just a couple duffel bags right now
and everything's already met yeah I
don't know yeah totally yeah we just
move in with a couple bags into these
environments and what else is is looking
to be crazy is that it's transitioning
into even you don't even need your
duffel bags anymore you don't even need
a computer in your phone you just go and
you log into the already existing
technical infrastructure
yes spatial computing infrastructure in
that location and the clothes that you
need this is already all connected to
the artificial intelligence grid where
they already know you you know your shoe
size your a couple pieces of clothing
you need at that location at that time
all part of the shared economy etc so
all very very interesting as you travel
from city to city okay a couple things
are on the way out
it's um I'm I want to I want to I want
to talk about this because this seems to
be the in many ways to future we've seen
things like The Venus Project
we've seen things like our ecology
taking over architecture and ecology
mixed together we've been talking a lot
about moving away from monolithic
buildings into into porous green
architecture sustainable architecture
taking ethos as a principle
communicative design all this stuff so
where do you see the future of the
architecture in design when I see the
future
well I mean in a way I kind of want to
double back on what we were just saying
in some ways well you kind of fed me a
good answer here I it's almost it's kind
of we work work of a keishon of space as
well right that that uh perhaps in a way
architects might be necessary in a
different way we're designing systems
and an opportunities less than we're
designing custom one-off happenings
right that it's more about understanding
how were implicated in creating the
systems that people arrive in and plug
in and and I think it's also probably
about coming together as well as a field
because I think architecture has always
been a disparate field of kind of
singular individuals or ideologies which
I think you find in any any discipline
or practice and and I think it's the
political nature of humans that
generates that but I do think architects
power is in is in numbers because I do
feel like society has not fully
understood what we do and why we bring
value or how we bring value beyond just
being the people that are on the ground
kind of drawing the buildings and going
with building department and making sure
that everything's code comply and all
that all the practical parts of
delivering it but it's we're also the
people that that create human experience
that way because
the spaces we're in if that's the thesis
of this conversation in a way they
influence the way we think the way we
feel the way we make decisions that's
very well understood in retail
architecture I frankly I'm kind of
excited to see other people outside of
our typical boundaries see the value in
architecture there was I'm gonna give
you an example and maybe your audience
can look into this further if they're
interested this was talked about quite a
bit here in LA so there's a really
prominent architectural school down the
way literally probably a mile or two
from here it's called a Sai arc which is
a Southern California Institute of
architecture and very recently Kanye
West actually showed up unannounced with
a crew of his of his his compadres to
walk through the student reviews there
the student design project reviews at
SCI are sweet and this got very well
published because obviously we know
Kanye has it you know he's kind of a
well-known cultural figure but it it it
gave architecture a moment and a lot of
people have been writing about this
happening and been talking about what
happened and we had our five minutes of
fame in a way oddly enough that
architects are forgotten about but Kanye
gave us a micro spotlight for a moment
that that him thinking as this kind of
visionary person thinking that
architecture had real gravitas in
society gave us a little bit of credence
in a little bit of us along the way
I think we're moving towards an era of
people that see the architect and
designing from a perspective of these do
directly influence the way that we
communicate with each other that we
think like you said this thesis of this
conversation and so I'm glad you brought
that what okay I want to ask couple
questions on the way out awesome what
would you say is a core driving
principle of your life
growth yeah to put it simply I
well something I'd like to say to people
are that I found myself saying quite a
bit is it maybe it's try it in a way but
my two favorite things in the world are
people and and learning so if I can find
a person I can learn from I'm just like
set so I would say that's that's often
how I in the end up pursuing various
social relationships or when I really
feel myself drawn to a person or or an
experience it's it's usually because
that experience a person is whether
directly or indirectly inspiring me or
bringing bringing new ideas to me and I
think certainly I I would argue that
that's maybe why there was immediate
kind of all I know is you know I think
we're probably drawn to that same
approach yeah I think it we just start
at day one we're all showed up growth
and learning with each other yeah yeah
percent so I love that principle that's
a really good one so so growth learning
in people people yeah that's so good
how about if you could rebuild
civilization from scratch how would you
design it
so it first I want to ask is that the
physical world is at the structure of
society politics structure of
civilization okay
I think
I think one of them
the biggest missed opportunities that
exists is that we have a world filled
with people that don't know how much
potential they actually have and maybe
that's I don't know maybe that I don't I
hope that's not throw away and I hope
it's not superficial and it's good dive
deeper into ye-yeah okay
I think we're a world that's and I don't
want to come off just like a rational
utopianist but maybe I am we are in a
world that's driven so so profoundly by
people's impulsive emotions that way
right and and people's judgmental
emotions and people's deluding emotions
so I think what we really need to or in
this hypothetical question where I'm
restructuring humanity we need to find
that a way through society that we
basically it allow people to to step
outside of their immediate feelings
because I think at the end of the day at
this this kind of political battle that
we're having this kind of ideological
battle that we're having people don't
understand that that's happening on the
level of individual people's personality
psychology and emotions right and
that it's not necesarily that there's
one right political answer or wrong
political answer we are just we are
simply acting in the world as a direct
result of of what's going on up in our
individual dome right that were
predisposed because of personality type
to see the world in a certain way we're
biased beyond experience we're biased
personality and psychologically speaking
and I don't know how you structure the
world in a way that you help people step
outside of that for a moment and and and
see if soom out forty thousand feet and
be like wow if I could be empathetic and
and really understand why this person
thinks that or why this person is doing
that or in any number of things I think
to allow a structure that facilitates
that for a broad population would with
reap incredible results
because there's there's so much value
tied up in people to there's so much
latent value because you have this world
filled with people that that have
already made up their minds about what
what their opportunity is or what what
they're capable of or who they are and I
would say that with myself I mean maybe
this is just a personal thing and a
projection of my internal world that I
found that through experience through
time that and once again this is maybe
this is trite but it's it's you it's all
about how you frame what you think your
identity is like there's always gonna be
people that are gonna try to tell you
what your anything is but if we can in
mass empower people to define their own
identities that's really good yeah I
like that as a design principle for and
I'm not sure how you write and I'm not
sure acting how to do it yeah but I um a
lot of it has to do with the degrees of
freedom so er so raising the baseline
for basic needs to be met yeah and then
degrees of freedom its Maslow's
hierarchy yes yes yes so the basic needs
are met to the point of like
self-actualization so there's
unconditional love and all these other
basic needs and then from there the
degrees of freedom are free of equality
of opportunity to pursue whatever you'd
like but just know that in order to
actually build something at that's at
the tippy-top scales it's gonna require
a lot more work than if you want to
potentially just do something a little
more relaxing in your day to days and
whatnot okay anyway
two more are we in a simulation I love
it
are we in a simulation well I a question
like that I would want to start with I
think we have to define simulation first
rate that's very less important part so
a simulation implies inherently that
you're recreating or you're you're
creating maybe not a false version but
an alternative a recreated version of
something else as a simulation let's say
is this base reality or simulation right
is this the actual earth that evolved
from the Big Bang orbiting a star or is
this a simulation of all the laws of
maths and physics that are just existing
in a place that is not the actual
physical reality right but bizarrely
what I like about this is is in order
for the concept of a simulation to even
exist right it assumes that there is
this other alternative universe that
we're mirroring or that we're we're kind
of copying so I would say that seems
like a pretty elaborate ruse I would say
that it's probably not a simulation I
don't I don't think I don't think
something okay last question what do you
think's the most beautiful thing in the
world
I think I've been answered maybe in a
way but
it's the most beautiful thing in the
world
how would I give you an abstract answer
and a panful answer I think the most
beautiful thing in the world abstractly
is truth and I think the most beautiful
actual physical thing in the world is
perhaps its
still abstract but I'm just gonna I'm
gonna say I want women yeah yeah
absolutely yeah I I loved I loved I
loved those answers um tell us a quick
bit on why truth and why women sure
truth because it's incredibly empowering
and I think that's sort of what I was
alluding to in your earlier question
regarding how do we if I was to idealize
and manifest an ideal Society would be
one driven by truth which is kind of an
ancient idea
you know there's ancient philosophers
talked about that but we still do today
yeah right well digging and figuring
things out but easier to self-actualize
people when the degrees of the
foundation of truth are actually present
in the education of every child and I
mean if if you don't know the truth how
do you how do you work for that that
space of falsehood essentially you can't
build up you can't build a building on a
rotating foundation yeah to me that's in
summary that's what truth is and women
and women well I mean might be obvious
reasons as a male that but I think what
I find particularly fascinating about
that answer in that way of framing it up
is that it's both this very biological
may be in and and an instinctual
appreciation of this difference or this
which is kind of a what would you say
it's like a companion to those yeah man
yeah right it feels like somebody who
there and I and I also want to I want to
preface this with saying that I'm
certainly somebody who ya like leaves
already yeah leaves in a broad spectrum
of types of people and types of
deceiving your gender and your identity
I don't want to I don't want to frame it
up in some sort of afeared kind of black
and whites away by a binary way but it's
almost like it's more of an appreciation
for a set of traits that are maybe in
some ways I feel different than mine or
complimentary that I do find that they
will just say the feminine spirit and a
broad sense I think often can manifest a
sense of compassion a sense of yes of
relational value yeah that I think
sometimes we we get him we get on our
high horse and we come into situations
and we want to we want to be dogmatic
and we want to intervene and I mean
broadly people want to do that but I
think maybe that archetype represents a
desire to understand first rather than
to to intervene and to yeah that's
that's very interesting there's a just a
couple things there the the rising of
the feminine spirit to co-mingle with
this masculine spirit that we've built a
lot of civilization with this super
exciting time so super exciting times is
to see what actually happens we we like
running simulations of what civilization
would have evolved like if it was a
matriarchy
yeah could have there been a deeper
sense of compassion and understanding
and maybe less war potentially who who
knows where would innovations be how
green or peaceful etc all these
different kind of things
also women in general and this is
everything from like a mother yes yes to
us who we absolutely love and adore all
the way to the women that we engage with
in like a formal like business sort of
sense that are giving incredible ideas
for building civilization but also in a
romantic sense as well I'm adoring the
female as well so this is like this is
such a beautiful way to I'm happy you
said that as an answer I think we're too
politically correct even sometimes say
that so I'm glad you did in truth so
many profound takeaways from this
conversation heaven this has been such a
pleasure wow thank you so much generous
and super super important to take away
this principle of understanding the
communicative fabric with which we
architect and design our world and
really getting behind the the the eyes
of the people that have built
civilization the buildings we walk
through the complexity of them the
software that's now being used to help
make it happen the ethos of
communication this is all super exciting
go and think about that more mull that
over more write your thoughts in the
comments below we'd love to hear from
you everyone thank you so much for
tuning in check out evans links below as
well and keep supporting awesome artists
and entrepreneurs that you believe in
like Evan like ourselves keep supporting
it so we can continue doing cool things
like coming on site and doing epic shows
like this and go and build the future
everyone go and manifest your destiny
into the world create build we love you
so much and we will see you soon beast
that's it my man oh man those great